with destiny too on the horizon and all
this talk about 4k and frame rates I
think it's a good time to take a quick
look at what resolution means how it
affects our games and why you should
care about the shift in pixel count
PCs are capable of power beyond any
current console but the Xbox 1x is
breaking new ground by offering native
4k while the ps4 Pro has its own
solution for higher resolutions though
performance may vary but this discussion
is prompted by our time playing destiny
- in 4k on PC which ran around 60 frames
per second using a beefy GTX 10 atti
graphics card so let's take a step back
for a moment with the emergence of 4k
some of us still need to wrap our heads
around what this means it's shorthand
for a resolution of 3840 by 2160 derived
from a generous rounding up with the
horizontal pixel count 4k results in a
whopping eight million two hundred and
ninety four thousand four hundred total
pixels four times as much as 1080p so
it's needless to say that running native
4k is incredibly intense for systems
it's no wonder that Sony and Microsoft
are pushing upgraded versions of their
current consoles as a display market
ships to 4k they roughly need four times
the power to run games somewhat
competently at this ultra
high-definition resolution I'm as much
of an advocate as any for 60 frames per
second and maintaining high frame rates
since it literally impacts how I play
the game and effects my overall
enjoyment which is why it's
disappointing to hear that the Xbox one
X version of destiny 2 is capped at 30
frames per second while no comment has
been made as to why I have a feeling
that has to do with parity and
competitive balance among players on
different Xbox consoles this highlights
the importance of frame rate the higher
your frame rate the smoother the game
runs from 30 to 60 frames per second the
game's image is updated twice as fast
closer to simulating real motion and in
a shooter the ability to make precise
shots in the heat of battle can be the
difference between victory and defeat
there will be intense PvE scenarios in
competitive PvP so the conversation
about running for cake inherently
involves frame rate imagine trying to
snipe a fast-moving player if the image
is updated at half the rate your
displays capable on PC there are so many
variables a whole list of quality
settings resolution anti-aliasing
texture filtering and of course ^ your
rig it's accepted that frame rates will
fluctuate across the user base but at
least it's in your hands
and with the right monitor you can get
120 144 and even 240 Hertz refresh rates
which is essentially the maximum frame
rate your display puts out 60 Hertz is
the most common so 60 fps is the golden
number for most users but there's no
denying that Triple A games with grand
spectacle really reach to the full
visual potential with the highest
resolution we just have to ask ourselves
at what cost
both for your wallet and your frame rate
now you won't be able to play the
destiny to beta on xbox 1x since the
console releases later this year but
$500 will get you a machine capable of
native 4k but on PC you'll probably
spend over $1000 although you'll get an
uncapped framerate not to mention the
ever-changing cost of a 4k display the
destiny to beta and full release is fast
approaching so you should probably align
your expectations with the hardware you
have if you're itching to play this game
in 4k in a way yes you should care that
Triple A games like destiny 2 are aiming
high with 4k visuals even for someone
like me who's still chilling at 1080p I
still pay attention to how games perform
in 4k and the capabilities of each new
piece of hardware because many of us
will make the jump in the near future as
4k becomes more cost-effective we just
scratch the surface on concepts like
resolution and framerate and we'll be
doing a deep dive real soon and with the
destiny 2 beta coming next month and the
full game later this year we'll have
plenty of content like guides and a full
performance analysis so do yourself a
favor and subscribe to GameSpot for all
that good stuff and one more thing
we have a few limited edition USB sticks
to give out from the event that you can
probably put to better use and all you
have to do to be eligible to win is
subscribe to our Channel and answer this
question what was in videos first GPU
leave your answer in the YouTube
comments to enter for your chance to win
good luck thanks for watching